Critic: I told you we just reviewed a fantastic four movie, I'm not doing another one!
Tamara: But it was SO bad!
Critic: I DON'T CARE!
Malcolm: They Couldn't even spell it right, 'fant4stick'.
Tamara: It got a half percent on Rotten Tomatoes.
Critic: How the hell do you do that?
Malcom: It found a way.
Critic: *SIGH*
Black Nerd: COWABUNGA!
Critic: AH!
Tamara: Black Nerd?
Malcom: Yes?
Tamara: No, that one.
Malcom: Oh.
Critic: What're you doing in the storage closet?
Black Nerd: I'm here to do the ninja turtle movie review with you and angry video game nerd, remember?
*FLASHBACK*
Critic: I don't care if the nerd is a bigger star, my face should be bigger than his on the title card!
*Ding dong*
Critic: Come on, who's a bigger ninja turtles fan than me?
Black Nerd: Hey Critic, heard you're Gonna do a ninja turtles crossover with the nerd?
Critic: Yea, sure come on in.
Critic: I don't care if i don't know anything about that one show.
Critic: Or that one.
Critic: Or That one.
Critic: Really?, they made another one?
Critic: I totally didn't know that.
Critic: But nevertheless, I'm the biggest fan and i deserve to be bigger on the title card!
Critic: Everything about me is bigger than him!
Critic: Including that!
Critic: DON'T ASK HOW I KNOW THAT!
*Flashforward
Tamara: Wait, you've been in the storage closet that entire time?
Black Nerd: Mmmmehh, it's not so bad.
Black Nerd: I still made videos.
Black Nerd: Hi I'm Andre and I'm a Black Nerd.
Black Nerd: Today i'm gonna be reviewing boxes again.
Black Nerd: YAY! BOXES!
Black Nerd: Which do you think is better?
Black Nerd: Cardboard or plastic?
Black Nerd: They both keep you alive if you ever need to eat them.
Black Nerd: Like i do.
*Munching sounds*
Black Nerd: I'm so cold.
Peter: Ya think that's bad? how about the time when-
Critic: Ok Enough with the cutaways.
Black Nerd: Soo, are you finally ready to do the review?
Malcom: Ummmm, we reviewed that a few months ago, didn't we?
Critic: Mmmm yeees, but seeing how i could be facing some serious criminal charges for this let's go ahead and do the crossover anyway!
Critic: It could be any movie you want!
Black Nerd: SMURFS!
Critic: Any movie you want!
Critic: I'm sensing an Earth Girls Are Easy vibe from ya.
Black Nerd: SMURFS!
Tamara: Fantastic Four!
*Punch*
Black Nerd: SMURFS!
Critic: Troll 2 it is! a low cliché but i still think we can get some good material out of it.
Black Nerd: Hellooo, police, Nostalgia Critic kidnapped another black guy again.
Malcolm: IT'S TRUE!
*Punch*
Critic: Let's do the f**king smurfs.
Black Nerd: yaaaaay!
Tamara: *Exhale*
Malcolm: ahhhh.
Malcolm: Man, Urkel did not age well.
Black Nerd: I heard that, Theo!
Black Nerd: The belgian comic turned into an american 80's cartoon and has finally hit the the big screen!
Critic: Well, technically the second time. Fucking liars.
Critic: Like most 80's cartoons it banked more on selling merchandise rather than focusing on interesting stories.
Black Nerd: You take that back!
Critic: NEVAAAAR!
Black Nerd: Police?~
Critic: It was mostly harmless.
Critic: So much so, that I'm not entirely sure how you could get THAT much of movie out of it.
Critic: At least without being super creative.
Black Nerd: Well that's exactly what they did, at first.
Black Nerd: Rumor has it Paramount originally owned the rights to the movie, and were looking to make it sort of a comedic epic fantasy!
Black Nerd: Think Lord of The Rings meets (The) Princess Bride!
Critic: Well, that doesn't sound too ba-
Black Nerd: Until Sony got the rights to the movie, thought Alvin And The Chipmunks was a big hit,
Black Nerd: And said: "HEY! we could do that, just make them blue!"
Critic: So wait, they're just ripping off that terrible chipmunks movie?
Black Nerd: Nooooooooooo!
Critic: Oh,thank god.
Black Nerd: They're ripping off 'The Chipmunks Movie',
Black Nerd: But they're also ripping off Enchaaaaaanted,
Black Nerd: And Fat Albert!
Black Nerd: And [In a British accent] Masters of The Universe.
Black Nerd: All that's messing is the crowning turd!
Critic: *gasps* No Black Nerd! Not Raja Gosnell!
Critic: He's the cinematic equivalent of child syphilis!
*Critic screams*
*Explosion SFX*
Black Nerd: *Evil laughter*
Critic: You fool! what have you done?!
Black Nerd: YES!, my satanic fellow! Let the world see you for the abomination that you are!
*Exhaling fire SFX*
Dragon: Would you like to buy some Smurf merchandise?
Critic: Evil takes many forms.
Black Nerd:This is the Smurfs movie.
Black Nerd: (whispering) I'll take two.
Critic: It opens with
Narrator Smurf.
Critic: No, really there's a Smurf called Narrator Smurf
Black Nerd: At least they're not hiding their laziness.
Critic: As he talks about a place that knows no sadness.
Critic: Well, clearly it can't be in this movie.
Narrator Smurf: A place inhabited by little blue beings...
Critic: Oh, so it IS an animated movie!
Black Nerd: No, that CG is supposed to look as convincing as
the human characters
NC: Really? they look like Rocky's coach if
he had Methemoglobinemia
Critc: It's a thing, read a book!
Black Nerd: At first, everything seems to be par for the course
The smurfs you recognize are all there,
they all have names that match their one
personality trait, and even the evil
Gargamel played by Hank Azaria plots to
catch them.
Critic: Ah, that evil entity who wants to destroy
the smurf's essence in order to become
disgustingly rich.
Black Nerd: Heey, I was talking about Gargamel, not SONY
(Crowd Oohing)
Black Nerd: Actually, in this
version he wants to Smurf's essence to
increase his magic, not to make gold or
eat them. And as you can see, he's not
very good at it as he spends most of his
time playing with puppets rather than
getting any real work done. Critic: Hey! At least they look
more real than the actual Smurfs! (shots fired) a lock ka boom! (??)
Oh god, Azrael. You're a boy?!
Critic: Well, any kids film opens with cat balls on a beloved characters head is
certainly setting the bar pretty high!
Black Nerd: Papa Smurf, voiced by Jonathan Winters, has a vision of all the smurfs being
destroyed because of a mistake Clumsy
made, never realizing that maybe he made
that mistake because you named him
Clumsy!
Papa Smurf: Clumsy!? Critic: Yeah it's like naming your daughter
"Prostitute" are you really encouraging
any great things labeling them that?
Black Nerd: Actually one of the stranger things is the
people they got to play most of the
Smurfs.
Critic: Oh come on, celebrity voices are
everywhere are you really surprised that
people like Katy Perry and George Lopez
are in this? Black Nerd: For the main characters, no.
But what if I told you that Pee Wee
Herman himself Paul Reubens was in this!
Critic: What where? Black Nerd: Right there. Pee Wee Herman on Blue meth: Heh Hee Heh! Black Nerd: And now he's gone!
Critic: W-What they called him in for just two
lines? Black Nerd: (giggles) He got the deluxe treatment
half of these celebrities barely even got a
word! That was Kenan Thompson! Critic: What?
Black Nerd: There went BJ Novak
Critic: Huh!? Black Nerd: Ooh! there's Jeff Foxworthy!
Critic: I didnt Even... Black nerd: Theres Wolfgang Puck! Critic: Why!
Black nerd: Dont miss Joan Rivers! Critic: They flew her in for this--!? Black nerd: And of
course John Oliver's one incredible line
John Oliver, also on blue meth: Oh marvelous! Critic: Please tell me he's there to do a report on how this movie is ruining America..
Black nerd: I think it speaks for itself
NC (im getting tired of spelling the names):You're right...
NC: So Gargamel finally figures out that the Smurfs have been kept hidden because of an invisible
force field. BN: As we've gone from
children's fantasy to Star Trek
technology. NC: But some of them stumble
across a magic portal....
Don't act like you haven`t! where Gargamel
has them trapped. Gargamel: Looks like you got the short end of the stick!
Eyy Papa!?
Papa Smurf: Not this time Gargamel!
NC Doing an impression of Papa smurf: I`d much rather sacrifice my
life then listen to your heinous performance!
Gargamel: Must... Have.... Smurfs!!!!!
BN: Because it makes much more sense to chase 6 Smurfs as opposed to 94!
Katy Perry taking the same drug as everyone who worked on the movie: I dont think We`re in Smurf Village anymore--!
NC: This leads them to wear every fucking
portal and family films leads to!
Both: New York City!
NC: Preferably the very pretty and/or
intimidating part.
Patrick Winslow: Oh, hey, can we get a photographer over there? There's an arrival happening. Thanks. Welcome.
NC: Uhhh.... why are we suddenly in an episode of How
I Met Your Mother?
BN: Oh don't you know? this is Neil Patrick
Harris` movie now! NC: What? I thought this
was about Smurfs!
BN: Well, Critic, like most sellout
adaptations the title character really
has anything to do with the title itself.
NC: So.. instead of being about little blue
people... BN: It's about an advertising VP
coming to grips with becoming a father!
NC: So... we're in a romantic comedy that just
happens to have Smurfs
BN: Yep..  NC:..That's like having a holocaust film
that's only decided it needs Fraggles
BN: That comes out next week. (Whispers) I hear Oscar buzz!
Papa Smurf: Until we rescue Clumsy and
get back home,
I need you all to stay close. NC: I know I
should be making fun of the product
placement but honestly, i'm just thinking
how much better this movie would be if
Blue Man Group played the smurfs BN: But they
wouldn't talk... NC: Exactly!
BN:And just when you're wondering if watching a cat vomit
would be more fun than watching this movie,
the film decides to answer for you.
NC: Infinitely more fun. BN: Yes. NC: It's like the disney world of fun in this
movie.
BN:(Half-Heartedly) Cat vomiiiit!
Garfamel: Tiny locks of Smurfette!...
Oh, sweet folecular (wtf) ambrosia! NC: Am I the only one getting a bald Moe Syzlak
from an unfunny version of The
Simpsons?
BN: So the simpsons now? NC: Up high- (High five)
Gargamel: Oh, I must find a laboratory! This should do nicely!
(Gargamel and CGI abomination step out panting)
Gargamel: Somebody's been working a dark and... terrbile magic in there! (Ironically movie's reviews)
NC:... Is it even worth wasting a joke on that one?-
BN: No, move on!
BN: While he tries to figure out how to get the magic out of her hair,
Neil Patrick Harris visits his
pregnant beard while the smurfs try to
break in.
Clumsy: Woah, ugh, ahh!
NC: And this partakes in what i'm noticing more and more in bad family
films, especially in Raja Gosnell's films-
movement pull. BN: What, your'e anti-movement?
NC: No, I'm anti lazy movement. Movement that
only exists just to hypnotize your kids
rather than engage them. Engaging
movement involves a lot of variety. Sharp
stops, varying speeds, unexpected turns,
this is what makes good visual
storytelling. Here everything is at the
same speed,  the same pacing, and the same
kind of movement. There is no variation
so there's nothing interesting about it.
What's more engaging, watching Mario go
one speed throughout the entire game, or
having him stop, slow down, go backwards,
stomp on things?
This safe, boring, and repetitive movement
is the same as looking at a watch waving
back and forth.
They're both trying to hypnotize and
relax you so that you don't think about
what you're watching,
and that's not what a movie is supposed
to do. You're supposed to think about
it, you're supposed to be sucked in!
But this method is an ingenious way to
numb your brains without feeling bored
so you think it must be doing something
right when really it's just junk food
for your mind, and it's all over the
movie.
BN: Oh, I don't know I don't think there's
anything wrong with a constant... source of...
movement...
BN: Hey guys! As you probably noticed-
-There's a jumpcut there!
-And there! And there! :D
-Some might say might say it's a fast-paced way...
-For me to save on memorizing lines!
-It is! :D
-Boop ba boo do dee... random thing!
-Do you know hard it is...
-To.. do..
-This.. in..
-One.. go?
Chester: Do I! BN: Chester, is that why you do the
fast editing? Chester: Is that what that is?
I thought it was just a wizard. BN: You never
question how you could do this?
Chester: When you're as high as I am, you learn not to
question things.
Both: WHEEEEEEEEE!
Both: Subscribe! Subscribe! Chester: Are we a magazine? BN: No, we're just supposed to say it.
Chester: Oh. Both: Subscribe! Subscribe!
(NC Stares disappointingly)
BN: (Sobbing) I'm a whore...
Nostalgia Critic Will Be Right Back!
BN: The Smurfs spot talent and decide to
attack him.  NC: Honey! Help!
I think they're gonna do me in the
Smurf! Patrick: Do not be fooled by their cuteness!
BN: So he's told who The Smurfs are and big
surprise, he finds it all kinds of
confusing. Grace: How crazy is this? They're little blue people!
Patrick: So, you're sticking with your "this is
actually happening" theory?
NC: That's actually a legit question, I
always had a theory that all this
movie was just a continuation of his
drug high from Harold and Kumar Go To White Castle
BN: No, not even a drunk person would go this
far without
SQUASHING THEM.
BN: Wanna get high?
NC: Yeah.
Patrick: Hear that, honey?
They're only staying till an actual blue
moon rises, which could happen if the
little blue Santa man makes a magic
potion which at this point seems
completely plausible.
BN: I don't think that was in the script, I
think Harris was just clarifying how
horribly written this movie is.
Patrick: And you're all named after your personalities? Do you get your names when
you're born or after you exhibited
certain traits?
Smurfs: Yeah. Yup!
NC: Ohhh, I see, so Clumsy has the personality trait of being clumsy, Grouchy
has the personality trait of being
grouchy, and Smurfette has the personality trait of...
Girl.
Just.. girl, as we all know all girls just have one personality trait
BN: Says so much about her. NC: Yeah.
Smurfette: (Excitedly) What?! You had one outfit on and now you're
wearing something completely different! Grace: Yeah, I...
Papa Smurf: Ah, Smurfette, she probably got the other one dirty.
NC: I love how they're shocked that she can
wear different clothes but not that
she's pregnant.
Having only one female made from nothing,
do you think they can even comprehend
the idea of a pregnant woman?
BN: Yeah, you'd think in this movie that go more into how Smurfs procreate.
NC: I say wizard. BN: I say artificial Smurf-ination.
Creepy Pervert: I have all the answers right here~
NC and BN: NOOOO!
CP: Your loss, there's some might fine blue balls in here!
I had to write on the cover cause you're not ready yet to see a Smurf get smurfed in the smurf
One of those smurfs stands for "anus"! ( ͡º ͜ʖ ͡º)
BN: But like most of Harris' performance, he
acts like he wants to get out of every
scene as quickly as possible.
Patrick: I had a crazy morning and haaaaii Odile: What are
you doing?
Patrick: Um nothing I'm just.. I'm excited!
NC: So tell me Patrick, is that a Smurf in your pocket or are you
just happy to see me? ( ͡º ͜ʖ ͡º)
Patrick: I need to home my message here. Gutsy: How about grab life by the great?
Smurf: Have a Smurfy day!
Smurfette: I kissed a Smurf and I liked it?
Both: GET IT?!
(Smurfs start chanting demonically)
Patrick: STOP! Come on, none of you find that song
just the tiniest bit annoying?
Smurf: I find it annoying!
(Black Nerd snickers)
NC: Did you just laugh at a Smurfs movie? BN: No. NC: Did you just laugh at a Smurfs movie?!
BN: No... NC: Just remember every time you laugh at
a Smurfs movie, God. Kills. A kitten!
It's in the Bible!
BN: Huh, I don't know how I missed that. NC: It's
in the hardcover, reads a little different
than the softcover.
BN: Gargamel uses a Smurf hair to make his magic better, catching
the eye of Harris's boss, played by Sofia
Vergara.
(Gargamel gibberish for 'I need to piss')
(Gross sigh of relief)
BN: Oh my god... NC: This is really happening
people!
BN: What do we do? NC: Just look away! BN: I can't it's
too awful! NC: Just close your eyes and imagine
one of your kindergarten favorites it's not
pissing into a bucket!
NC: Is it working for you?
BN: PEYO IS ROLLING IN HIS GRAVE!
NC: Me neither, there's only one alternative!
NC: It's just so much better for some reason! BN: Yeah,
me too... but I feel like we're missing
part of the movie. NC: Oh you're right, you're
right, let's rewind that and see what we missed...
(Mixed screams of pain, terror and anguish)
BN: The Smurfs end up in a toy store, where of course, all sorts of
misunderstandings take place.
Clumsy: I'm just tired of the whole dating game,
just say who you are and be who you say...
NC: Okay, first...
that looks nothing like a smurf, second
it's not even blue, third does he really
not know it's a pillow he has to know
it's a pillow I mean is that something the
Smurfs don't know, they just don't know
what pillows are? They have to have
pillows, their hats are kinda like
pillows, I mean for the love of God, HOW IS
THIS SCENE EVEN REMOTELY POSSIBLE-
1998 Jennifer Lopez: Really? Who gives a sh*t?
NC: Ah, thank you 1998 Jennifer Lopez, you're
right.
The more question it, the more it shows I
care.
Smurfette: Ooh, creepy. I hope they weren't looking for Stargazer too...
Dresses! You mean I can have more than one kind of dress?
NC: Wow she seemed to get past the impaled
heads and supposedly dressed up corpses pretty fast.
BN: must be that defined girl personality.
NC: Gargamel tries to catch them but ends up getting tased.
Now... that HAS to be funny, Gargamel
getting tased? Good god, how can a movie possibly screw this up-
(Gargamel spazzing out)
(STILL not funny)
BN: Like that! NC: You couldn't even make Gargamel getting TASED funny...
He sounds like Professor Fink getting jerked off!
BN: Ugh, I don't think we need that image. NC: Nah, I don't think so either.
BN: Much better. NC: Oh, but I feel like we missed part of the movie-
BN: In their spare time, Smurfette reveals her troubled past
Smurfette: I was.. created by Gargamel to trap the other Smurfs
Grace: Then what happened?
Smurfette: Papa saved me. He cast a special spell and then helped me become the Smurf I was meant to be!
NC: Oh! So much for her backstory!
BN: Yeah, who cares! We have Harris' advertising
job to worry about!
It's not like this movie is about Smurfs!
Patrick: Time to either celebrate, or file for unemployment...
BN: Huh, I think that was the
banner at the movie's wrap party.
NC: But we don't need to worry about that for too
long as we partake in more movement porn
which also conveniently serves as
trailer fodder- BN: -and product placement for
Guitar Hero and/or Rock Band
(Ball-rippingly bad rendition of Aerosmith's "Walk This Way")
NC: Was the Neil Patrick Harris crotch cam
really essential to the scene?
BN: I'll accept it. As long as the Smurfs
don't rap, as long-
(Surprise.)
BN: OH MY GOD! (Slams hand on table)
BN: Who're they even singing to?  I know it's supposed to
be like a music video, but in terms of the movie they're just rapping into a corner
Both: LA LA LALALALA LA LALALA LA
BITCH!
(Both continue to recite demonic chant into corner)
Tamara: Soo, uh... whatcha guys doin'?
NC: We're representin' foo!
BN: Yeah, playa if someone was down there lookin' at us we would look ama-zin!
Malcom: You look like you're being punished...
Both: WE ARE!
(Both sob)
Patrick: Doesn't it... freak you out sometimes?
Little guys depending on you?
Papa Smurf: That's what being a papa is...
(NC imitating Papa Smurf): As the saying goes, "You smurf it, y' raise it."
BN: Gargamel is put in prison which... let me see if anything funny is happening here...
BN: Nope.
As he magically summons an army of flies to save him.
(Gargamel screams as he is almost ripped to shreds)
(And dropped.)
NC: Boy, even by Smurf standards that's just
weird!
But it looks like Clumsy accidentally tripped and sent the wrong design to the firm.
As... most trips do? Which means the wrong ad is sent all over town.
Patrick: You said they would bring good luck, this is anything but good! I
never should have let this happen!
I never wanted a house full of little
people running around!
(Nice going.)
BN: No, it's okay I only just meant it as a
metaphor for the baby!
Grace: Of all the people on the planet those
magical little creatures came to us. They
chose (cursed) us. Don't you see how absolutely
amazing that is this? This a
once-in-a-lifetime thing Patrick, this is
our blue moon.
Kermit the Frog: Hm... y'know, it's amazing.
You are 100% wrong.
I mean, nothing you've said has been
right!
BN: Yeah, Kermit's right, nobody chose anybody.
NC: Yeah, it's clearly just a series of accidental circumstances.
BN: I'll give it this, though, it does make me crave blue moon...
NC: Let's go drinking after this... BN: I think that was a given.
NC: But
thankfully Times Square is full of ironic
imagery and he realizes that hammered in
messages are good.
BN: Meanwhile at an old bookstore, the Smurfs
are looking for a book of spells which
seems to be weirdly enough a Smurfs comic
book...
Papa Smurf: Secret rooms are hidden in the drawing...
Smurf: You see all that
in there? Papa Smurf: Look here, at the patterns on this page...
BN: So wait, Peyo wasn't just a cartoonist, he
was also a dimension jumper? NC: Or was he a
time traveler? Didn't this all take place in
the past? Kinda?
BN: And upon his discoveries all he
did was make cartoons about it?
I never though i'd say this but... Smurfs, you're
kind of hard to follow!
NC: Gargamel tries again to capture them
but Papa Smurf stays behind to get captured.
BN: Why?! He could have just escaped with them!
NC: Well, then it wouldn't feed into the Papa
sacrifice-y talk that they had
earlier. BN: That doesn't mean you get
purposely caught for no reason!
(Beautiful music starts playing) NC: Doesn't it Black Nerd, doesn't it?
BN: NO!
NC: Well the director of Beverly Hills Chihuahua says it does so shut it!
BN: Have you seen Beverly Hills Chihuahua? NC: No,
have you?
NC: (Whispers) You are part of the problem...
BN: But they get the portal to open up and bring
tons of Smurfs back to save Papa.
(Smurfs chanting MORE demonic chant)
NC: Yeah... that doesn't really work as a war
song. It sounds more like a lullaby from Donald Trump.
BN: Hm... an angry ward of people holding
weapons, chanting and wearing pointy white hats...
BN: For some reason I feel very uncomfortable...
NC: While that's going on, Papa Smurf is being
put through a machine to extract his essence
Papa Smurf: No! Onions! Agh!
NC: ....Was that a Smurf thing? Being afraid of onions?
BN: No.
NC: Was there an episode when an onion killed his family?
NC: Could the onion-
BN: No!
NC: Then why the f*ck is he afraid of onions!?
BN: I don't know! Indiana Jones is afraid of snakes!
NC: But not produce! There's not a
scene in one of the movies where he's like-
Onions? Why'd it have to be onions?
BN: Let's just
agree that the writers were probably on meth when they wrote this...
NC: There's no probably about it.
NC: Blue meth-  BN: Blue meth!...
BN: Wanna get high? NC: Yes.
BN: Oh but here's something neat we get
to see how Azrael gets the chipped ear!
NC: But... wait... if this happened after the
cartoon shouldn't there already be a chipped ear
BN: I guess it makes as much sense as
Smurfette saving Papa Smurf only to
immediately have him captured again.
NC: Christ, this guy throws himself into
trouble more than Bella Swan!
Clumsy: I got it! BN: But Clumsy is about to
perform the action that Papa Smurf saw would doom them all.
Papa Smurf: The visions... have never been wrong...
(NC as Papa Smurf): Except when they're completely wrong...
like this time!
BN: Just put that in the bag of other plot
holes this movie doesn't explain!
NC: Really? It's getting so big! (Slams bag on desk)
Papa Smurf: I owe you and apology, Clumsy... I believed more in a vision... than I did in you.
(BN as Papa Smurf): From now on you shall be called
semi-competent Smurf!
NC: This leads to the Smurfs finally being
sent home.
Papa Smurf: I should get going
I've got a smurf village to rebuild. Your
village has given me some ideas.
(NC as Papa Smurf):  We're thinking about putting our garbage on
the street and acting like assholes to
anyone who looks at us funny!
Patrick: I smurf you.
1998 Jennfier Lopez: Really? Who gives a sh*t?
NC: So that was the Smurfs
movie. BN: But only by title this has so
little to do with the original cartoon!
Believe it or not, in 2017, they're
rebooting the Smurfs AGAIN fully
animated and more like the source
material, which makes perfect sense,
because this movie has nothing to do
with the original Smurfs!
Look, you can do that with Garfield you can do that with the Chipmunks, but the Smurfs live in a
medieval fantasy world with dragons, with
wizards, with witches, with magic, with
sorcery, with adventure, and you
decided it was more entertaining to have
advertising executives, domestic
parenting, New York City,
Sony product placement?! That is not what
the Smurfs stood for,
it was magical, it was timeless and you
made it... 2000's!
NC: And yet, it was such a big hit. Why?
BN: I'll tell you why, because they threw a
lot of money and advertising at it with no effort.
People forget how all over the place the
Smurfs were. It was a marketing monster
that couldn't be escaped. It grabbed older
people's nostalgia, younger kids love for
toys and enough celebrities to have
people shrug and be way too forgiving
because of how cute it was. NC: So wait,
you're saying you can make a bundle
through no effort at all as long as you
just advertise it right? BN: Pretty much. All
you need is something nostalgic,
celebrities, and someone who's
manipulated people through advertising
before...
Narrator: Coming this fall to a theater near you...
PET ROCK. It's your childhood favorite
like you've never seen it before. It
jumps around to pop songs, looks cute,
raps in the corner,  alters some white
idiot's life, and all while having a ton
of celebrity voices. You remember these
people, age group 5 - 37, don't you?
it's Amy Poehler-
Amy: WAFFLES! :D
Chistopher Walken-
Christopher: Mm, call me Chris... Chris Rock!
Selena Gomez-
Selena: The rock wants what it wants
Hey, she said the thing!
And of course,  Samuel L Jackson-
Samuel: Yeah, i'm
in everything so why not be in this.. motha f*cka.
But you don't want a
movie called The Pet Rock to be about the Pet Rock,
so we have several characters to derail
the plot, like Neil Patrick Harris as the
ad executive, Megan Fox as April O'Neil,
Shia LaBeouf from Transformers-
Shia: DO IT.
Alright! Jeesh.
They're just about to ride with Natalie
Portman and Courteney Cox in a pink
convertible with He-man and Thor in the
back seat, with a soundtrack featuring
The Rolling Stones, Kid Rock, and other
rock related names.
You know it must be good, it's on f*cking everything!
PETROCK The
Movie
It'll turn your heart of stone into a
heart of home! Coming up the same weekend as-
NC and BN: SON OF A-
*Humming*
Is that camera still on?
Hey guys, Doug Walker
here
you know, every time I do a Nostalgia Critc, a lot of people tuned in and I
really wanted to do something good with
that and something i want to try that's
kind of knew is that I want to give a
shout out to certain charities that I
think are really worth your attention or
really worth your support
so I'm gonna do that at the end of every
video now i'm going to give a shout out
to some really special charities
preferably ones that I know it's
something about have had some contact
with and that's exactly what I'm gonna
do here i'm going to start off with a
charity that is very very special and
they're just we've seen him work first
and they're phenomenal that's OneStepCamp.Org
and this is a camp for
children who have cancer
here at at this camp here you're just a
regular kid and you can just feel like a
regular kid and we've seen it firsthand
because you're not seen as anyone different,
for you you're like any other kid and
all these kids come together and they
share so many incredible experiences and
I remember we were there on the last day
it wasn't it wasn't a dry eye in the
house I mean it was just seeing all
these kids come together
just having fun and hugging each other I
mean that they're saying goodbye to say
goodbye to each other and it was just it
was the most heartwarming thing you've
ever seen I mean it's just incredible
and these people do such great work
so if you have the time definitely go
check out their website and check out
the wonderful things that they do we've
done
uh charity drives for them before and we
talked to him in person they're just
phenomenal people and they are
definitely worth your time to check out
so if you can definitely go take a look
show your support and donate to
something that is absolutely wonderful